(audience clapping)
- Alright.
We always like to finish
up with something hopeful,
and today is no different.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
Nearly 40 million people
here in the US have diabetes,
and the price of medication
and supplies can really add up.
That's why one Arizona man
has made it his mission
to provide those necessities
to people in need for free,
which is incredible.
And the world of TikTok
has been quick to help.
Let's welcome the founder
of the Embrace Foundation,
watching on 3TV in Phoenix.
What's up, Brandon?
(audience cheering)
- Kelly, how you doing?
- [Kelly] I am so well.
So, this was born out of
your own experience, right?
- Yeah, I was diagnosed
when I was seven years old
with Type 1 Diabetes.
And in 2014, I aged outta
my parents' insurance,
so I was reusing pen needles,
I was skipping meals, skipping doses.
I would actually go around
to different hospitals
and endocrinologist's, even
my pediatric endocrinologist,
which I saw when I was in middle school,
to beg for little sample sizes of insulin
just to kind of get me by
until I was able to secure
a full-time job with good
insurance and health benefits,
and things like that,
because it costs so much.
It costs $700, if not more,
to sustain a diabetic lifestyle.
And in America, it's the
only place that's like it,
every other country, they give
it away essentially for free.
- Oh my gosh.
I can't imagine having
to beg for something,
obviously to live.
That's incredible.
So, can you tell us more
about the Embrace Foundation?
- Yeah, so, like I said,
there are so many other
Americans kind of going through
exactly what we're going through,
or what I was going through.
Going to college, or maybe
they're a single parent
whose child was just
diagnosed with diabetes.
So in 2020, I started
the Embrace Foundation,
and we are a nonprofit
organization that helps diabetics
all across the country get
the supplies that they need
for absolutely free.
We started in 2020, and with TikTok,
we got a ton of support.
We're getting supplies
from fellow diabetics
all over the country.
We're getting monetary
donations from people.
So, we're able to do it for free.
And since our conception in 2020,
we are able to send
out over 4,000 supplies
to diabetics in need.
(audience clapping)
- Oh my gosh.
So you're being the help
that you needed, man.
That's incredibly cool, Brandon.
I'm liking your post right now, alright?
(bell rings)
- [Brandon] Okay, thank you.
- And that's not all, my man.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Frixion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show",
love how you're helping fellow patients,
and want to help you do more.
So, they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- Thank you so much.
I appreciate it.
I'm only listening to
Kelly Clarkson from now on.
- Oh yeah!
- [Brandon] Only person I
thought about.
- [Kelly] Thank you so much, Brandon.
Have a great 2023, alright.
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
Alright, thank you to
all our guests this hour.
Kate Walsh, Randy Jackson, Paul Rabil,
Tim and Lauren Ziering.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, well, try and change it.